تصوير قطار الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
قد يضعك على حافه خطر حقيقي الكلام هنا
منقول عن مصور هاون وجد نفسه مضطرا للهروب
من روسيا لتجرائه على تصوير وعرض صور قطار
بورت في اكثر بمناسبه يتعلق الامر
الذي لا يزال يتذكر جيدا القطار
الذي استخدمه بوتين بعدما ظل يلاحقه
لسنوات سعيا لالتقاط صور له بروتكوف كان
اول من ينشر صورا لقطار الرئيس وكان ذلك
عام 2018 قبل ثلاثه اعوام من اطلاق
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
اعجابه وامبياره بالقطار دفعه الى حد
القول ان البشر العاديين لا يسافرون في
مثل هذا القطار
المصور الهاوي ظل يطارد قطار الرئيس بوتين
لسنوات طويله في بنسبه له كان العثور على
القطار وتصويره انجازا في حد ذاته وحسب
المصور الروسي فان القطار كان مطليا
باللونين الاحمر والرمادي وكان اشبه بقطار
اشباح حيث ان جدوله الزمني كان سريا كما
لا توجد ارقام محدده لقاطراته فضلا عن ان
نوافذه مراقبه بشكل دائم كما ان جميع
القطارات المجدوله الاخرى تفسح المجال
للقطار الرئيس اثناء مروره وتحتوي احدى
عرباته على قبه غير عاديه في الاعلى تضم
على الارجح معدات اتصال خاصه
عن مصادر لصحيفه واشنطن
استخدم القطار بشكل متزايد منذ عام 20 21
لصعوبه تتبعه
مثل الطائرات
المصور الهوى تلقى في بايو سرت 2021 رسائل
تظهر المحادثات التي كانت تدور بينه وبين
مراقبي القطارات الذين كانوا يساعدونه في
تحديد موقع قطار بوتين حينها اكتشف انه
مراقب من طرف جهاز الامن الفيدرالي وبان
الرسائل التي وصلته كانت مجرد تحذير بنسبه
له بعدها قررت توقف عنه روايته بملاحقه
وتصوير قطار الرئيس وقرر الهرب خارج
البلاد خوفا من سجنه واعتقاله وفعلا غادر
وسلسله الماضيه حيث توجه بدايه نحو
كازاخستان ثم الهند والان هو هارب في
سيراليك